herr präsident der geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen die über zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer es ist ja verlockend im
wahlkampf jetzt drei wochen vor der
bundestagswahl zu versprechen keine
sorge es wird alles so bleiben wie
bisher
aber die menschen in unserem land wissen
doch dass wir nur das erhalten können
was uns lieb und teuer ist wenn wir
endlich veränderung angehen wenn wir uns
endlich den großen herausforderungen
unserer zeit aktiv stellen und nicht
weiter abwarten diese bundestagswahl
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben das sehr
treffend gesagt ist eine richtungswahl
diese bundestagswahl ist eine
richtungswahl weil sich entscheidet ob
die nächste bundesregierung noch aktiv
einfluss auf die klimakrise nehmen kann
oder nicht und deswegen muss die frage
klimaschutz im mittelpunkt der nächsten
bundesregierung stehen
[Applaus]
und ich finde das nicht nur befremdlich
sondern ich finde das wirklich auch mit
blick auf all die menschen in unserem
land die gerade alles tun um im aartal
und an anderen orten wiederaufbau zu
leisten da sind friseure da sind
handwerker die unter der woche arbeiten
und dann am wochenende am wochenende
kommen und freiwillig helfen häuser
wieder aufzubauen
finde ich es wirklich unverantwortlich
dass hier in dieser debatte zur lage
deutschlands in dieser situation wie
darüber sprechen dass zu recht das
unterstützen wir aus vollem herzen 30
milliarden euro für den wiederaufbau
bereitgestellt werden aber diese 30
milliarden euro werden doch nichts daran
ändern dass wir in zukunft bessere
vorsorge treffen wenn solche
extremwetter ereignet wieder kommen die
werden nichts daran ändern dass wir
klimaschutzmaßnahmen betreiben oder
nicht wenn wir ernst meinen dass dieser
moment einen moment war über den wir
nicht hinweggehen können bei menschen
alles verloren haben dann muss
klimaschutz im mittelpunkt der nächsten
bundesregierung stehen als klima geben
weil wir eine verantwortung haben als
politik eine verantwortung dafür haben
menschen zu schützen ich war wie sie
letzte woche wieder vor ort und da
stehen einem bundespolizisten gegenüber
und beschreiben noch einmal die
situation dass helferinnen und helfer
eigentlich vor ort waren aber dann der
digitalfunk der digitalfunk im jahr
2021 nicht funktioniert hat wir haben
erschreckende berichte darüber gehört
dass feuerwehrleute gesagt haben wir
hätten drei tage früher kommen können
wir hätten hubschrauber schicken können
aber es hat nicht funktioniert weil es
keine gemeinsame zusammenarbeit im
katastrophenschutz mit der bundes gegner
gibt und sie stehen hier und sitzen hier
einige wochen danach und dieses ganze
thema wie wappnen wir uns zukünftig
gegen diese katastrophen spielt hier
absolut keine rolle da schützt unsere
sicherheit in zukunft nicht wir brauchen
endlich eine klimapolitik die auch
vorsorge und schutz gebaut ist und das
bedeutet auch ein bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz kassierer
verantwortung übernimmt bei ja
verantwortungsvolle politik bedeutet
dass man aufgrund eines solchen tages
seine politik ändert wenn man sieht dass
seine politik in die sackgasse geführt
hat was denn sonst was denn sonst sollen
wir tun wenn wir erleben das
extremwetter ereignisse zu nehmen was
denn sonst sollen wir tun wenn die
erleben deshalb südeuropa abbrennt das
jetzt in new york wasserfluten in u bahn
schächte herr einstürzen das ist auch
der punkt wo man handeln muss und wo man
sich sagt wir machen einfach weiter wie
bisher und dann schauen wir mal das ist
das größte risiko unserer zeit und
deswegen die zentrale aufgabe für unsere
generation
und hier sind genannt wahlkampf ja wir
sind in einem wahlkampf herr scholz und
herr laschet aber wahlkampf noch nicht
über die sorgen der menschen einfach
hinwegzugehen junge menschen und zwar
nicht nur freies for future die auf die
straße gehen sondern man hört dass von
psychologinnen und psychologen man hört
dass von erzieherinnen und erzieher dass
kinder sich sorgen machen darüber wie
werde ich eigentlich in zukunft in
diesem land leben was passiert
eigentlich was passiert eigentlich wenn
meine kita gerade weggespült wurde diese
frage hören erzieherinnen und erzieher
jetzt in nordrhein westfalen und in
rheinland pfalz und da können sie doch
einfach nicht sagen auf die ängste
dieser kinder versteht doch bitte unsere
angst über eine benzinpreis debatte ist
noch viel größer nein wir sind die
erwachsenen wir sind die politikerinnen
und politiker die sagen wir werden alles
dafür tun diese ängste zu nehmen weil
diese ängste sind real ein kind was 2018
geboren ist die erlebt nicht einmal in
ihrem leben ein jahrhundert hochwasser
sondern nach all den prognosen die wir
derzeit haben werden diese hochwasser
alle zehn jahre kommt diese sturzfluten
alle paar jahre kommen und deswegen ist
es jetzt zeit dass politisch zu
verändern und sie sagen dann von der fdp
und von der cdu das soll mal der markt
regeln vielleicht haben sie heute die
zeitung aufgeschlagen in der sz wurde
das noch mal berechnet wenn das allein
der markt regeln soll dann kostet die
tonne co2
2800 euro
das ist zutiefst sozial ungerecht und
die klimakrise die regel kein markt weil
dem markt sind menschen herzlich egal
es braucht eine politik es braucht eine
politik die sagt wir machen das jetzt es
braucht eine politik gesagt wir machen
das jetzt anstatt 17 jahre weiter in der
kohle drinzubleiben 17 jahre weiter und
entscheid unterscheiden sie sich
zwischen cdu und spd an keiner stelle
und er scheut sie reden ja oft von
respekt aber wie respektvoll ist es in
die lausitz zu fahren und sagen ich
werde weiter für den kohleausstieg
2038 eintreten und ein paar tage später
dann bei den umweltverbänden zu sagen
2034 wäre eigentlich auch ganz in
ordnung das ist für mich kein respekt
sondern das zeugt davon dass es keinen
kurs in der klimapolitik gibt sei der s
idee und bei ihnen wenn sie dieses land
anführen wollen
17 jahre weiter und sie haben ja sie
haben wir ein klimaschutzgesetz
beschlossen wo richtigerweise drin steht
denn ein sektor das nicht erreicht da
muss man schauen wie das in einem
anderen sektor geregelt wird wenn sie 17
jahre lang weiter co2 aus kohle
verstromen wollen dann bedeutet das dass
das so viel co2 ist für alle gebäude
zusammen dann erklären sie mal den
mieterinnen und mieter dass die jetzt
die ganzen klima aufgaben übernehmen
wollen weil sie nicht den mut haben den
kohleausstieg auf 2.030 endlich
vorzuziehen
das thematisch an der situation deswegen
dass jetzt kein finger schnippt werden
wird wie wir diese klimaneutralität
erreichen können ist dass sie acht jahre
als große koalition dieses land regiert
haben in einer zeit der
vollbeschäftigung der guten und
sprudelnden steuereinnahmen niedrigster
zinsen und einfach diese chance nicht
genutzt haben sie haben es vermasselt
auf gut deutsch den weg zur
klimaneutralität endlich einzusteigen
und das ist schön dass sie sagen wir
reden jetzt auch seitdem der wahlkampf
begonnen hat mit stahlkonzern und
chemiekonzern die das eigentlich sehen
wissen sie die deutsche industrie ist
schon seit ein paar jahren deutlich
weiter als diese bundesregierung der bdi
hat auf seiner jahrestagung deutlich
gemacht die fehlende planungssicherheit
weil es keine richtungsentscheidung von
der großen koalition gegeben haben ist
eines unser größten probleme für den
zukunftsstandort deutschland und ich
zitiere hier mal hier angus wurm es
reicht nicht klimaneutralität per gesetz
vorzuschreiben die politik muss auch
dringend etwas dafür tun dass dieses
ziel auch erreicht werden kann und
politische entscheidungen treffen und
genau darum geht es jetzt nicht
klimaschutz auf zuzuschreiben sondern
politische entscheidungen zu treffen und
das heißt zwei prozent der landesfläche
bedarf nutzen das bedeutet den
kohleausstieg vorzuziehen und ab 2030
nur noch emissionsfreie autos zuzulassen
und es bedeutet auch eine solarfläche
auf jedes dach und dass sie selbst
diesen antrag hier im deutschen
bundestag nicht zugelassen haben
beziehungsweise über geschäftsordnung
weggewischt haben zeigt rennen die große
koalition wenn sie herr scholz oder sie
herrliche demnächst hier weiter regieren
wollen dann wird das mit den
klimaschutzzielen einfach nichts werde
und jetzt in einer situation wo die wo
die finanzielle situation eben nicht
mehr so gut dasteht wie in den letzten
jahren müssen wir klare prioritäten
setzen weil die frau bundeskanzlerin
haben von den gleichwertigen
lebensverhältnissen gesprochen ja das
steht in unserem grundgesetz dass es
eine der zentralen aufgaben aber wenn
wir mal genauer hinschauen in unserem
land dann erleben wir ein riesengroßes
problem das wir neben nicht nur in
ländlichen regionen kein internet haben
sondern in ganz ganz vielen bereichen
unseres landes bei der digitalisierung
dem zukunftsthema nicht erst seit heute
sondern in den letzten zehn jahren sind
wir bei den 20 größten industrienationen
auf dem drittletzten platz das ist ihre
regierungsbilanz von acht jahren großer
koalition in der digitalisierung im
schienenbereich es ist so dass
mittlerweile jede sechste weiche jede
sechste brücke und jedes sechste gleich
reparaturbedürftig sind und jetzt
sprechen sie über modernisierung die
modernisierung hätten sie in den letzten
acht jahren angehen müssen
und wenn wir dieses weiter so nicht
einfach hinnehmen wollen dann müssen sie
sich jetzt klar entscheiden und
priorisieren sorgen wir jetzt für
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
investieren wir jetzt in unsere
infrastruktur oder nehmen wir weiterhin
dass wir ein investitionsstau von 140
milliarden euro in unserem land haben
und ich will das nicht ich möchte dass
man auch im ländlichen raum mobil
unterwegs ist ich möchte dass wir auch
an allen orten in unserem land
vernünftige schulen und ein internet
haben und deswegen braucht die
schuldenbremse eine erweiterung durch
eine investitions regel und dass sie
sich der weitere finanzminister
gegenstellen zeit dass der respekt vor
der zukunft offensichtlich nicht so groß
ist all diejenigen die wirklich mal
unterwegs sind im leben die erleben doch
was das bedeutet wenn wir nicht in
unsere daseinsvorsorge investieren
grundschülerinnen und grundschüler der
dritten vierten klassen noch nicht
schwimmen können weil die schwimmbäder
im ländlichen raum zu machen
ebenso kunst und kultur alle haben
gesagt ja irgendwie dieses
systemrelevant aber genau da wird jetzt
gespart werden wenn wir eben die
investitionen nicht bereitstellen und
dass sie in so einer situation als union
jetzt sagen unsere steuervorschläge sind
vor allen dingen die reichsten zehn
prozent zu entlasten anstatt in die
daseinsvorsorge und den zusammenhalt in
unserer gesellschaft zu investieren
zeigt auch in welche richtung sie sich
in zukunft entscheiden
und er heftet da hilft es aber wenig
dass ihn jetzt herrscht ein feld das wir
eine kindergrundsicherung brauchen wir
haben das hier im deutschen bundestag
immer wieder in all den jahren
diskutiert und es bei ihrem ministerium
im familienausschuss was immer wieder
deutlich gesagt hat ach nee
kindergelderhöhung darüber reden wir mal
aber die frage von anhebung der
hartz-iv-regelsätze das gehen wir nicht
an jede mutter die weiß wie es am ende
des monats von den hartz4
kinderregelsätzen als familie zu leben
die muss sich an so einem schönen
sommertag immer wieder überlegen eis ist
nicht drin schwimm akt ist nicht drin
die neuen fußballschuhe sind sie auch
nicht drin weil das was ihre kinder und
familienpolitik bisher war für jedes
kind in diesem land bedeutet dass man 1
euro 50 zur verfügung hat als mutter für
sein kind und das reicht vorne und
hinten nicht aus
und weil wir gerade bei steuern und
gerechtigkeit sind wer ausgerechnet
den kampf gegen steuerbetrug lieber
weiter mit fax und brief führen will
denn frage ich wirklich ernsthaft
welcher gesellschaft wollen sie
eigentlich dienen und dass sie sich dass
sie sich aus angst vor einer fetten
dicke schlagzeile in einer großen
zeitung genau in diesem moment auch als
finanzminister weggucken zeigt
offensichtlich dass sie aus warburg und
wirecard nicht wirklich etwas gelernt
haben
der amtszeit den hosting einige von
ihren schon zweimal hier geschworen
haben aber vielleicht in seiner
bedeutung mittlerweile vergessen haben
der am zeitgeist kraft dem wohle des
deutschen volkes widmen und schaden von
ihm zuwenden und schaden von ihm
zuwenden bedeutet vorzusorgen eine
vorausschauende politik zu machen im
klimaschutz bei der frage gerechtigkeit
und vor allen dingen auch mit blick auf
den kampf gegen die pandemie
wir stehen gerade wieder vor einem
corona herbst wir sehen dass die
infizierten zahlen massiv nach oben
steigen und die hospitalisierung quote
wir haben krankenschwestern pflegern und
ärzten gesagt das wird nicht noch einmal
passiert dass wir hier klatschen und ihr
tag und nacht durcharbeiten müssen und
was passiert jetzt es müsste jetzt
einige entscheidung getroffen werden von
dieser bundesregierung von cdu und spd
zu sagen wir rauschen nicht nochmal in
synchroner herz sein und er bringt es
nichts zu sagen ich verspreche die
schulen bleiben offen und ich verspreche
es wird kein weiteren locker und geben
sondern ihre aufgabe ist jetzt dafür zu
sorgen dass das auch kommt und das heißt
in einem solchen moment den mut zu haben
dass es an hotspots natürlich auch eine
zweig regelung geben muss damit die
schulen in zukunft auch wirklich offen
bleiben und kinder nicht in die achte
ferien rauschen wo es heißt jetzt einmal
wieder einfach nichts getan
um den schülerinnen und schüler zweimal
die woche getestet werden warum soll das
nicht auch am arbeitsplatz möglich sein
diese debatte hatten wir schon mal in
diesem hohen haus und nach anderthalb
jahren ist es an der zeit dass das
endlich umgesetzt wird
und dann kann sie eigentlich
gesagt sie wollten jetzt in drei stunden
über afghanistan und eine
verantwortungsvolle außenpolitik
diskutieren das war ihr argument von cdu
und spd warum sind sie dem top per
geschäftsordnung afghanistan hier nicht
zugelassen haben und dann ist es doch
ein ganz schön hohe stück das sie sich
dann hier hinstellen auch sie herr
scholz und nichts zu diesem thema sagen
nichts dazu sagen was in den letzten
wochen eigentlich in dieser kulisse her
und schieben ist und seit der seit der
letzten afghanistan debatte sind jedoch
neue dinge an das licht der
öffentlichkeit gekommen dass sie die
listen von denen wir hier vor wochen
gesprochen haben gar nicht weitergegeben
haben dass menschen vor dem flughafen
standen angerufen worden sind und dann
standen sie aber nicht auf der liste
drauf und durchzukommen stattdessen
wurde diese listen mit namen von
menschen die in lebensgefahr schweben
irgendwie an die taliban gegeben und
dass sie darüber hier und heute nicht
reden wollen das ist einfach
unverantwortlich
und es geht
es geht dabei nicht nur um die
zukünftige außenpolitik der
bundesrepublik deutschland es geht auch
um die frage welche art von politik
wollen wir eigentlich machen eine
politik wo sich eine regierung in
schwierigen momenten einfach weg durch
eine politik wo sich eine große
koalition hinstellt und sagt mit dem
parlament möchten wir darüber jetzt
nicht diskutieren
das ist nicht nur eine unverantwortliche
außenpolitik sondern das zeigt auch dass
man kein respekt vor diesem hohen haus
hier hat und dass die
verteidigungsministerien jetzt alleine
ein lösungsansatz in ihrem haus durch
setzt sie aber nicht bereit sind das
hier im deutschen bundestag zu
beschließen das ist wirklich ein unding
und ja sie können das per
geschäftsordnung tier von der
tagesordnung aber sie für ihre
verantwortung beim afghanistan debakel
nicht einfach wegwischen in der nächsten
legislatur wird es ein
untersuchungsausschuss dazu geht
und zwar nicht nur nicht fehler
aufzuarbeiten sondern weil deutschland
endlich wieder eine aktive deutsche
außenpolitik braucht dieses wegducken in
der afghanistan politik ist doch ein
spiegel dessen was passiert ist in den
letzten acht jahren in europa
deutschland ist das stärkste land in der
europäischen union deutschland ist das
land was immer wieder sagt wir wollen
europa eigentlich weiter bauen auf ihren
eigenen koalitionsvertrag
haben sie irgendwie vergessen
offensichtlich in den letzten vier
jahren stand als obertitel drauf ein
neuer aufbruch für europa und was ist
dann passiert
als er gesagt hat wir müssen jetzt mal
den globalen kampf gegen steuerbetrug
wirklich angehen mit blick auf eine
digital steuer haben sie gesagt herr
scholz ach nee lassen wir das lieber mal
sein geld sind sie nach getrödelt mit
reichlich verspätung und die franzosen
haben erst mal alleine gemacht als eine
eu kommissionspräsident in von der union
gesagt hat europa soll der erste
klimaneutrale kontinent sein fällt die
nichts besseres ein weiter in brüssel
dafür zu lobbyieren das aber mit blick
auf die auto grenzwerte bitte mal nicht
so schnell gemacht wird und jetzt macht
das halt daimler alleine die stellen ab
2025 nur noch e autos her und das und
das und das heftigste das heftigste ist
passiert und ich komme zum schluss herr
präsidentin der europäischen
flüchtlingspolitik
humanität und ordnung sind die pfeiler
unserer gemeinsam werte union und was
haben sie vier jahre lang gemacht sich
unter viktor orban versteckt und gesagt
so lange der sich nicht bewegt bewegen
wir uns auch nicht europa wurde immer
gebaut dass einige sich zusammengetan
haben beim euro bei schengen bei der ost
erweiterung und genau dieser moment den
brauchen wir jetzt wieder in deutschland
was europapolitisch führt und sich nicht
hinter viktor orban versteckt
ihren fonds angekündigt einen aufruf für
europa ist nichts übrig geblieben außer
einer reise meiner beiden mitbewerber
diese woche nach paris um das letzte
noch zu retten so gestalten wir nicht
nur ein aufbruch in europa sondern so
wird es auch dem klimaschutz nicht und
deswegen brauchen wir eine regierung die
verantwortung übernehmen den mut für
neues werk für einen klimagerechten
wohlstand in deutschland und eine
zukunft einsame europäischen union
herzlichen dank